kommen zum internationalen Frühschoppen
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive läuft
seit Wochen bislang ohne größere Erfolge
nun bittet die Ukraine Deutschland um
Marschflugkörper der Kanzler zögert die
USA ebenfalls wie geht es weiter in
diesem Krieg in dem laut Schätzung fast
500.000 Soldaten getötet oder verletzt
wurden
ein Land im Krieg und sein Präsident
seit Beginn auf der Suche nach
internationaler Unterstützung nach
militärischer Hilfe
ich danke allen Regierungschefs und
Staaten die der Ukraine helfen unser
Land zu verteidigen und damit die
Sicherheit aller Menschen auf der Welt
luftverteidigungssysteme für die Ukraine
und auch Waffen für unsere Krieger
immer wieder gefordert Kampflugzeuge die
USA wollen die Weitergabe von F16 Jets
an die Ukraine jetzt beschleunigen
Genehmigung an die Niederlande und
Dänemark soll nach Abschluss der
Pilotenausbildung erteilt werden
nach den USA ist Deutschland
mittlerweile der zweitgrößte
Waffenlieferant für das angegriffene
Land allerdings lehnen nun die meisten
Deutschen die Lieferungen von deutschen
Taurus Marschflugkörpern an die Ukraine
ab
und Frankreich das Land sicherte die
Lieferung von Marschflugkörpern an die
Ukraine zu allerdings mit geringerer
Reichweite als die Taurus
Chinas Haltung zum russischen Überfall
auf die Ukraine ein Balanceakt in Moskau
sichert China Putin seine Unterstützung
zu
laut Beobachtern beträgt der
militärische Anteil der
internationalenhilfe mittlerweile über
70% Kampfjets und Marschflugkörper wie
weit geht die Unterstützung der Ukraine
das ist unser Thema heute hier im
Frühschoppen und ich freue mich sehr auf
meine Gäste bei uns ist Catherine Klüver
ashbruck sie ist Publizistin bei der
Bertelsmann Stiftung und bei uns ist
Chieming er ist freier Journalist und
Publizist und für Frankreich bei uns ist
Pascal tibow erst Großbrand bei Radio
France und Moritz Eichhorn begrüße ich
in dieser Runde erst Leiter des Politik
Ressorts der Berliner Zeitung der
ehemalige US-General Ben Horst hat
Deutschland und den USA mangelnde
Entschlossenheit bei der Unterstützung
der Ukraine vorgeworfen hat gesagt
scheitere die gegen Offensive müsste man
Deutschland und die USA verantwortlich
machen teilen sie seine Analyse nein so
weit würde ich nicht gehen ähm ich
glaube wir erleben weil die Diskussionen
die Taurus
der Debatte um die Leopard Panzer aus
dem Januar und es gibt viele Parallelen
auch damals waren grün und FDP dafür in
der SPD gab es Zurückhaltung der Kanzler
zögerte die Amerikaner wollten nicht
liefern
immer noch nicht in der Ukraine sind es
gibt aber ein signifikanten Unterschied
und das ist der Stellenwert den die
Debatte in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit
einnimmt es gibt einfach heute ganz
andere Themen als vom halben Jahr
wirtschaftliche Themen Inflationen
Migrationsdruck das heizungsgesetz und
die Ukraine ist dann Stück und die
Waffenlieferung sind ein Stück in den
Hintergrund gerückt und ich glaube der
Kanzler kann da auch gar nicht mehr tun
ohne sie genifikante Teile der
Bevölkerung zu verlieren auf die ganzen
Themen die jedes Land auch noch
natürlich beschäftigen kommen wir vor
Klima wie sehen sie es äh dieser ja doch
harte Vorwurf einer
Mitverantwortlichkeit sollte die gegen
Offensive scheitern also ich glaube es
ist nicht ganz falsch dass ich sowohl in
der deutschen Hauptstadt wie auch nur
Washington noch mal auf die eigenen
Schuhe geschaut wird und zu schauen
welche Dinge hätten schneller gehen
können denn das was der amerikanische
Präsident natürlich sich selbst
versprochen hat aber eben auch seine
Öffentlichkeit versprochen hat ist das
diese Sommer Offensive schnell gehen
würde und ich glaube was wir jetzt
lernen ist der es wird unterstrichen
quasi was Mark Milly der Chef des
Generalstabs gesagt hat aber das sagt er
eben schon seit November das wird ein
langer Krieg das wird ein blutiger Krieg
und das wird vor allen Dingen ein
Stellungskrieg und wir haben jetzt
Geheimdienstinformationen diese Woche in
Washington gesehen die glaube ich die
Entscheidung für die F16 und die
Freigabe der F16 noch beschleunigt haben
was sind das für exzenten die das die
Ukraine mit der jetzigen Taktik und wir
haben eine taktische Veränderung gesehen
über den Sommer die die Stadt militopo
nicht wieder einnehmen können wird und
für die amerikanischen Militär es ist
die Einnahme von also das hinwirken
darauf dass die Landbrücke zur krimin
abgeschnitten wird das wäre ein ganz
entscheidendes Signal auch
innenpolitisch zu sagen unsere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine zahlt sich
aus wenn das nicht zu Fall kommt weil
die Ukraine ein Taktik Wechsel
vorgezogen haben nämlich eher auf die
kleinen Verbände setzen auch noch viel
um bachmut und im Osten zu tun und da
sind jetzt fangen an sich die
Bruchstellen zu zeigen dann hat Herr
weiten zu Hause ein Problem und wir
haben eine Umfrage gesehen von CNN in
den letzten zehn Tagen wie gesagt haben
55 Prozent der Amerikaner sind
inzwischen gegen eine weiter umfassende
Ukraine Hilfe gerade hat er noch mal
eine Anfrage um 13 Milliarde Dollar an
den Kongress geschickt und wir haben
eine Wahl die ins Haus steht also
innenpolitisch druckmomente sind real
für den amerikanischen Präsidenten und
F16 kommen zum Teil deswegen natürlich
mit diesem entsprechenden Abstand aber
damit er zumindest noch den Ductus
retten kann das ist schneller gehen
könnte wenn Geräte da wäre das heißt die
schnelle Weitergabe
16 Kampfjets dann über Dänemark und die
Niederlande
in Frankreich ist die Situation ja ein
bisschen anders
macron hat sich ja schneller entschieden
Marschflugkörper zu liefern aus welchem
Grund
ja ich glaube der hat auch seine Meinung
gerettet und seine Strategie geändert
wir verfolgen alle in Deutschland diese
heftigen Debatten von denen wir gerade
gesprochen haben wenn jedes Mal eine
neue Waffengattung geliefert werden
könnte in Frankreich findet eine solche
Debatte nicht statt das ist gar keine
Debatte wie weit diese Hilfe gehen kann
es gibt also auf jeden Fall nicht
vergleichbar mit der Debatte die in
Deutschland stattfindet aber das hat
auch mit einer anderen Geschichte was
Waffenlieferungen angeht auch in
Krisengebieten da ist man traditionellen
in Frankreich wesentlich weniger
zurückhalten als in Deutschland
und man muss trotzdem betonen dass
Frankreich sie haben die Kritik
gegenüber Deutschland in den USA gerade
erwähnt dass Frankreich an sich
verglichen mit seiner Wirtschaftskraft
weniger weniger getan hat alles als
Deutschland und Frankreich hat auch Zeit
gebraucht um
verschiedene Waffensysteme zu liefern in
der Tat im letzten Monat hat
hat rund um den NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius
macron entschieden diese
marschflusskörper Skype das sind die
Zwillingsbrüder sozusagen der der
britischen zu liefern die haben eine
geringere Reichweite das haben wir
gehört als die Taurus aber immerhin ist
es ein eine ein zusätzlicher Schritt ich
glaube dass man
verstanden hat in Frankreich dass man
mit der sagen wir mal piecement Politik
der ersten Wochen und Monate gegenüber
Russland nicht weiterkommen das ist eine
Sackgasse und das der Druck auf Moskau
in direkt sozusagen besser erreicht
werden kann wenn man sich entschieden
entscheidet
effizienter mit militärisch militärisch
die Ukraine zu zu unterstützen und
nebenbei
nähert man sich den Positionen der
osteuropäischen und nordeuropäischen
Ländern während Frankreich in der erste
Zeit eher wegen dieser Zurückhaltung in
diesem Teil Europa beschäftigt
kritisiert wurde in der Tat ist dann
Wandel passiert so wie sie skizziert
haben ein Wandel den man in China mit
Sicherheit auch sehr aufmerksam verfolgt
das ist ja so dass es eine Entwicklung
gibt wir erinnern uns am Anfang wurden
Helme geliefert und mittlerweile
sprechen wir über Marschflugkörper wie
wird das in China beurteilt diese ja
schlagkräftigeren Waffensysteme und
deren Lieferung ich glaube Peking
beginnt jetzt ähm diese ganzen Kriege
als eine Art Lektüre zu lesen bestimmte
Muster Verhaltensmuster also von
stahlhelmännern bis zu Marschflugkörper
das verbindet die eine ganze Kriegslogik
wenn du da sagst musst du B sagen sonst
ist auch das Vergessen und picking
verfolgt ist aus einem eigenen Interesse
denn
in Pazifik in Asien Pazifik in du
Pazifik passiert etwas im Hintergrund
vergleichbares also diese diese Treffen
der gerade in Camp David
für einen Moment vielleicht noch
wirklich Menschen sind also der wird
auch diskutiert welche Waffensysteme
welche militärische Systeme zueinander
passen gegen wen gegen welche Gegner und
so
Peking studiert das auch deswegen weil
Peking sich verrechnet hat mit Russland
so am Anfang war es ja so dass innerhalb
von 72 vielleicht 96 Stunden der Krieg
vorbei war
ist aber nicht vorbei und auch die
chinesische Position
wir verkaufen uns das Friedenstaube
fruchtet kaum kaum gibt es noch eine
Initiative durch chinesischen
Friedensbemühungen sondern eher noch
also der Arabien Türkei und alle anderen
das heißt also Peking rechnet nicht mehr
mit einem russischen Sieg es ist nur
noch eine Frage ob Peking mit einem
großen ukrainischen Sieg rechnet und
wenn nicht dann ist diese Logik sehr
wichtig für beginnen also wenn jetzt
Körper geliefert werden und den nächsten
großen Stufen noch kommen wenn also
Moskau die demnächste Kriegsziele sind
dann wird es natürlich in Peking ganz
anders gelesen dann wird es
wahrscheinlich Peking eines Tages auch
Kriegsziel sein dann wird es nicht mehr
nur um Thailand gehen ist das aus ihrer
Sicht der Grund der russische
Verteidigungsminister war ja in Moskau
sich hatte Putin noch mal seine
Unterstützung zu danach allerdings nach
Belarus und beide Staaten haben ja auch
jetzt noch mal angekündigt militärisch
stärker zusammenarbeiten zu wollen ist
das sozusagen der Schritt den China
jetzt unternimmt
noch mal einen eigenen Akzent zu setzen
zumindest außenpolitisch in einem
symbolischen Akt ja also wenn ihr vor
unserer Haustür mit südkorea Japan
Philippinen Vietnam alles veranstalten
gegen uns dann veranstalten wir voll
eure Haustür mit Weißrussland etwas egal
was egal wie substanziell das sein kann
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen sehr
substanziell weil sie chinesische
meditierkraft so weit nicht reichen
würde aber das ist egal aus dem
politisch ist das Signal klar so wie du
mich behandelst in unserer Region so
behandle ich dich da natürlich auch das
hast ja auch ins Bild als die Chinesen
angekündigt haben sie können sich
vorstellen dass die Militärübungen in
KUB machen also genau die gleichen
Distanzen im Grunde genommen also
wirklich da bekommt man so ein Gefühl
für auge um Auge Zahn um Zahn das passt
auch in das in das erweiterte Bild
absolut ist steht also das was auch
zwischen den Zeilen jetzt in Camp David
verabredet wurden es geht ja prinzipiell
abgesehen von den schweren Gerät was wir
hier besprochen haben weiterhin um diese
155 mm Artillerie Geschosse und das
jetzt südkoreanische Geschosse da
wirklich in den Gebrauch kommen um das
auszugleichen was der Westen nicht
zusammenfügen kann jedenfalls nicht in
der Schnelligkeit das kann ich mir
vorstellen dass es ein Peking sehr
schnell so gelesen wird als ob sich da
doch eine internationale Militär
Koalition zusammenbaut die dann und da
möchte ich den noch mal bei Pflichten es
gab in der vergangenen Woche eine Studie
die noch mal sehr weit gelesen wurde aus
uppsalat noch mal um wie gehen solche
world of attrition solche langen Kriege
entweder werden 24% davon im ersten
Monat beendet 26%
deshalb oder der ersten Wochen 26
Prozent so in den ersten paar Monaten
und wenn es darüber hinausgeht dann sind
es im Schnitt von 1946 bis 2001 gemessen
über zehn Jahre und wenn wir uns auch
noch mal das andere waffengerät
angeschauen wann sollen die abbreams
kommen wann wären die F16 wirklich
einsetzbar dann wird doch im Hinterkopf
die ganze Zeit schon gerechnet dass wir
mindestens noch zwei oder drei Jahre in
diesen Krieg investieren und das wird
internationale Koalitionen verändern
aber dann auch andere geostrategische
Fragen stellen und das ist ja auch genau
das die ersten Ankündigungen dass dieser
Krieg sehr viel länger gehen wird die
gibt es und es gibt ja aktuelle Umfrage
hier in Deutschland die Deutschland
trennt wo einfach auch nochmal bezogen
auf die Arsch vom Körper gefragt wurde
und da ist ja eine knappe Mehrheit gegen
die Lieferung dieser Marschflugkörper
was glauben sie aus welchem Grund
ja ich hatte eben schon kurz erwähnt
dass es einfach andere Probleme gibt die
Bürger in Deutschland unmittelbar in
ihrem Alltag betreffen das sind
Preissteigerungen das ist mangelnder
Wohnraum das sind
alle möglichen von unmittelbaren Fragen
die sozusagen an den Geldbeutel gehen
und die man erlebt auch in den Schulen
in etc die deutsche Wirtschaft schrumpft
als eines das einzige G7 Land der
schrumpft in diesem Jahr und der
Ausblick ist eben nicht mehr so positiv
ich habe mir noch mal die Mühe gemacht
und geguckt wie die Zustimmung zur
Stimmung von Leopard Panzern im Januar
vor der Entscheidung war und da hielt
sich dass die Waage also es war ja fifty
fifty und im Osten was zum Beispiel so
da war 59 % dagegen jetzt sind es 70 %
die gegen die Taurus Lieferung sind also
da verliert man auch ein Teil der
Bevölkerung so scheint es zumindest ich
glaube es sind eben andere Probleme die
ins Zentrum rücken aber ich wollte noch
mal einmal kurz zu diesem Muster zurück
also es ist ja doch so weil heute sagt
vielleicht sind die oder er macht die
Deutschen und die Amerikaner ein Stück
weit deutlich wieder scheitern der
Gegenoffensive wenn sie dann wirklich
scheitern solltest weiß man ja am Ende
auch noch gar nicht die Ukraine sind ja
für Überraschung gut aber es ist doch so
was sind denn die Alternativen wenn die
Ukrainer wirklich durchschlagenden
Erfolg gegen die Russen hätten oder
umgekehrt die Russen wirklich die
Ukraine niederringen würden all diese
Ergebnisse sind für den Westen ja
eigentlich inakzeptabel bei einer
Niederlage der Ukraine hätten wir
Flüchtling wir hätten Potentaten auf der
ganzen Welt im Mund hat auch solche
sozusagen kleinere Nachbarn zu
überfallen und bei einem Sieg der
Ukraine wir müssen gar nicht über
Atomwaffen reden Russland ist
offensichtlich nicht so stabil wie man
denkt man hat es an Herrn brigoschen
gesehen wenn das Land zerfällt dann
haben wir ganz andere Probleme als das
was in der Ukraine gerade passiert das
heißt ihre These ist man gibt so viele
Unterstützung wie nötig aber eben auch
nicht darüber hinaus was ja unweigerlich
so viel zum Verlieren zu wenig zum
Siegen das würde ja wirklich
unweigerlich in einen ganz langen
abnutzungskrieg führen und genau das ist
ja etwas was zumindest laut den
Äußerungen von macron offenbar in
Frankreich dann doch anders gesehen wird
oder
ich glaube es liegt ich glaube er ist in
manchen in vielen Ländern ist man dran
interessiert dass dieses Grund dass
dieser Konflikt natürlich nicht so lang
so lange dauert wie eben in dieser
Studie unterstrichen weil es andere
Prioritäten gibt weil die Länder die
jetzt massiv oder weniger massiv die
Ukraine unterstützen auch andere
Prioritäten haben insbesondere die
Länder wie die USA oder Frankreich etc
die haben eine internationale Agenda
wollen sind auch in anderen Regionen
tätig und äh
Sie diese und außerdem hat diese Kriege
in dieser Krieg war noch Implikationen
auch in anderen Regionen sie wie manche
brix-staaten und auch in Afrika
reagieren und nicht so reagieren wie die
Länder die
insbesondere im ukrainische Konflikte
tätig werden mit Ihrer Unterstützung
also man ist in dran interessiert das
ist zu einem Ende gibt ich habe den
Eindruck dass man vielleicht anderswo
als in Deutschland sich mehr Gedanken
macht
nicht unbedingt vielleicht offiziell
unter eins in meinem Journalisten Jargon
sagt also wie ein Ende aussehen könnte
weil jetzt hat man den Eindruck wir
wissen eben nicht wie das wie das am
Ende ausgeht aber dass man man hat man
man hat in einem bisschen den Eindruck
man ist jetzt wie im Jahre 1914 ja man
gewinnt ob der einen Seite einfach
Quadratkilometer der anderen Seite
wieder vielleicht mit weniger Toten aber
wie kann es zu Ende gehen welche
Kompromisse müssen gemacht werden musste
die Ukraine auch international auf ein
Teil seines Gebietes verzichten wie
Nicolas Sachkunde das eben vorschlägt in
seinen Erinnerungen was für Schlagzeilen
wieder diese wiederum gesagt hat
ist der ist ein eine eine eine ein ein
seine Mitgliedschaft in der Natur eine
Perspektive einmittel ein Druckmittel
also all das wird glaube ich erwogen in
den Kulissen ohne dass man dass man die
Öffentlichkeit nicht so viel davon
bekommt
etwas was immer wieder von
unterschiedlichen Seiten durchdringt was
könnte ein Weg sein in dem die Ukraine
möglicherweise dann doch Gebiete abtritt
von den beiden Beteiligten Russland oder
Ukraine ist die Bereitschaft ja ganz im
Gegenteil zu spüren funktioniert die
Strategie des Westens in dieser Frage
aus ihrer Sicht also ich glaube der
Westen kommt jetzt genau an den Punkt
den Herr tibu beschrieben hat nämlich
das ganz deutlich wird dass wir
eigentlich keine schlagkräftige oder
skalierte Strategie haben das ist auch
ganz deutlich das haben die Amerikaner
diese Woche sehr klar gespürt
Bruchstellen mit der ukrainischen
Militärführung gibt trotz der ganzen
Trainings 66000 ukrainische Soldaten hat
der Westen trainiert über diese letzten
anderthalb Jahre und trotzdem machen die
Ukraine eben ein anderes taktische Spiel
als z.B die Amerikaner oder die Briten
ihres vorgeben würden umgekehrt sehen
sich der Westen aber natürlich in der
Falle die die im Grunde genommen schon
angesprochen hat der Westen kann nicht
laut sagen wie zum Beispiel einen
Friedensprozess es wird spekuliert
könnte es eine Situation geben wie zu
Beendigung des Koreakriegs zur
Erinnerung das hat zwei Jahre gedauert
575 diplomatische treffen aber dann
mussten natürlich erstmal beide Seiten
quasi ja sagen dazu es gab eine viel
offensichtliche und offensivere
internationale Beteiligung auch der
Amerikaner natürlich also weil die im
Kriegsgeschehen einbezogen waren ist das
überhaupt eine Lösung oder wäre das
überhaupt denkbar angesichts der auch
verhärteten Fronten im Kopf die Tatsache
ist ein Herr Stoltenberg in den letzten
10 Tagen wieder hat sowas anklingen
lassen da gibt es direkt quasi implizit
aus dem präsidentschaftsbüro in der
Ukraine den den Schlag zu sagen nein
unser Ziel bleibt immer noch das gesamte
Territorium zu befreien also der Westen
kann zumindest nicht öffentlich darüber
reden wie dann quasi einen ein
diplomatischer Weg aussehen würde und
umgekehrt scheint es sich der Westen
auch nicht rechts zu machen also wir
haben die Bemühungen Saudi-Arabien
gesehen ich glaube das war richtig
selbst werden keinen also die Tatsache
dass man mit dem globalen Süden auch
noch mal spricht darüber welche
langfristigen Auswirkungen gerade
Ernährungssicherheit
wassersicherheit Transport
Wirtschaftsfragen also nochmal
Inflationsdruck wird erhöht durch die
Tatsache dass Wasserwege jetzt
abgeschnitten sind und und und dass man
die noch mal mitnimmt aber so richtig
scheint der Westen nicht über den
eigenen Schatten springen zu können um
das nochmal zu konsolidieren zum Teil
eben auch weil die druckmomente kommen
und diese US-Wahl die da kommt die ist
für alle Seiten wichtig Herr Putin will
diese US-Wahl bis ums Erbrechen in
Anführungszeichen abwarten denn dann
könnte sich sein gesamtes Schicksal
ändern ne wenn Donald Trump im Weißen
Haus sitzt und umgekehrt hat herben fürs
nächste Jahr spürt er jetzt schon
unglaublichen Druck diese Sorte von
Unterstützung noch durchzustehen und
wenn er da jetzt Fehler macht dann kann
ihm das umgekehrt in der Wahl um die
Ohren fliegen und wenn wir einen ich
habe das exekutiv autokarten im Weißen
Haus sitzen haben dann fällt der Boden
aus dem globalen System der 70 über 70
Jahre lang unsere Friedensordnung
unterstützt hat also diese Wahl im
November die ist entscheidend und da
spielen viele auf Zeit lassen Sie uns
gerne später noch mal dezidiert auf die
Wahl gucken weil in der Tat man ja an
diversen Momenten den Eindruck hat
Putins Strategie könnte auch sein
einfach nur so lange abzuwarten bevor
wir dazu kommen vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz zu dem zu der Frage NATO
Mitgliedschaft Ukraine da ist es ja so
dass bei den naturgipfel in Vilnius man
sich auf die
Sicherheitsgarantien einigen konnte zum
Teil auch sicherheitszusagen genannt
kann das der Ukraine helfen vielleicht
Herr eichhörn zuerst ne ich fand das
sehr interessant was Freiburg ja eben
kurz angerissen hatte das war ja äh der
staatsche bzw Büroleiter von der
Stoltenberg der in der vergangenen Woche
bei einer Podiumsdiskussion in Norwegen
gesagt hätte ja die Ukraine könnte doch
Land abgeben und dafür Frieden bekommen
und das sozusagen was abgegeben wurde
dass sozusagen seine Art von b-ukraine
und die andere Ukraine wird dann in die
NATO aufgenommen man müsste vielleicht
eine Art von demilitarisierter Zone
dazwischen haben aber er sagte auch
nicht dass die Idee von ihm selber
gekommen sei bzw aus den NATO
Hauptquartier er wollte aber auch nicht
sagen von wem also ich glaube das ist
womöglich ein tragfähiges Konzept wo es
eine reale nato-perspektive gibt
mit der Dauer der Zeit werden natürlich
auch die Kosten an sozusagen Mann bzw an
Menschen immer höher sie hatten darüber
gesprochen wieso die Ukraine nicht die
Taktik wählen die die Amerikaner Ihnen
vorgeschlagen haben das ist eine Taktik
bei der sehr sehr viele Menschen sterben
würden weil sie eben ihre gesamten
Kräfte auf eine Stelle schicken würden
wo die Russen sie massiv dezimieren
würden und man dachte die Ukraine werden
bereit diesen Flugzeug zu bezahlen sie
haben sich aber eher für eine
nadelstichtaktik entschieden also wir
sagen aber je mehr Verluste ist gibt
desto wahrscheinlich mancher denke ich
doch werden selbst wenn Herr kolleber
direkt auf so einen Vorschlag reagiert
mit nein das würden wir niemals
akzeptieren wird im Hintergrund darüber
geredet und natürlich wissen die anderen
auch also Ukrainer wissen auch dass in
den Vereinigten Staaten gewählt wird und
es gibt ja nicht nur Herrn Trump es gibt
ja auch nicht nur ein descendis ist klar
ist schon in die amerikanische
Perspektive kommen würde ich mich noch
mal dafür interessieren das ganze Thema
NATO ist natürlich auch was was China
sehr
beruhigt wenn man jetzt so etwas hört
Sicherheit zusagen oder in der Tat die
Vorschläge über die wir gerade schon
gesprochen haben was die chinesische
Perspektive darauf
also die die die Datum Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine wurde in China immer schon
sehr genau beobachtet auch schon 2014
als es losgehen china hatte er damals
der
kovic
ein
[Musik]
militärhilfe-paket angeboten mit
analogen
als Inhalte nach China würde die Ukraine
abdecken wenn du keine nuklear von denen
man anderen angegriffen wird von dem den
Sonntag von Russland von von Wissen das
heißt dass ich innerhalb ein generelle
sind Interesse dass sie NATO bitteschön
nicht noch mal wächst egal wohin ja und
jetzt kommen noch einen zusätzlichen
Interesse weil die Ukraine ein Test war
ist also wenn die Ukraine in welche Form
auch immer der NATO beitreten wird
damit der nächste Schritt in der NATO in
passieren die NATO die überlegt sich
hier schon ein Büro in Japan aufzumachen
Japan hat schon 2018 die ganze
japanische Botschaft im Belgien zu einem
Mission für die NATO aufgemacht die
ganze Botschafter diente auch der
Kontakt zwischen mir Japan und Datum und
das wäre natürlich eine NN entschiedenen
Schritt der ganzen geopolitischen
Struktur in in Fernost also dann ist es
nicht mehr die USA der alleine hinter
Japan stehen es ist auch nicht mehr nur
Deutschland und Frankreich sondern eine
gesamte Militär
Bündnis weltweit
das heißt also die chinesische
Berechnung ist so so weit es geht müssen
wir den NATO in dem jetzigen Rahmen
halten bitteschön nicht weiter ja es ist
schlimm genug wenn Schweden und Finnland
mit dabei sind ist es schlimm genug wenn
das die die NATO-Truppen entgegen alle
Versprechungen die jetzt an der
Ostgrenze stehen 300.000 Mann ja bitte
nicht weiter und wir sind bereit zu
sagen okay wir machen auch etwas anderes
vielleicht nicht ganz so wie ihr euch
gewünscht habe aber wir provozieren auch
nicht so weit wie wir sagen
uns direkt jetzt mit Russland nein bloß
nicht wenn wir das machen es ist eine
sichere Sache dass nicht nur die Ukraine
in der Natur ist und irgendwann ist auch
Japan und Südkorea in der NATO ja das
Thema ging es ja jetzt auch zusammen bei
diesem Treffen in Camp David wo sich ja
in der Party Regierungsoberhaupt der von
Japan Südkorea und den USA
zusammengefunden am Sommersitz des
US-Präsidenten was für eine Bedeutung
hat dieses Treffen aus amerikanischer
Sicht also das ist passen die Strategie
eines amerikanischen Präsidenten
international ein Flechtwerk der
Allianzen herzustellen leiders work of
the lionces nennt Jack Sullivan der
nationale Sicherheitsberater das was die
USA macht den Ausbau der
orkusverbindungen Ausbau des Cord mit
Indien zusammen und Korea nicht nur in
einen lose Absprache sondern auch
wirklich in mögliche also gemeinsame
Militärübungen besonders auch natürlich
der Austausch von Geheimdienst
Informationen also überhaupt einfach so
Länder des erweiterten Westens wenn man
so will in den sogenannten Kreis des
Vertrauens reinzuholen und weil wir
gesehen haben ist es ja wirklich eine
weitreichende
ein weitreichende Erklärung gewesen eben
interessanterweise mit Partnern südkorea
Japan die viele historische Differenzen
weiterhin haben als man muss das eher
als
Dreiecksverhältnis sehen und nicht
irgendwie als als Kreis in dem Moment
aber es ist natürlich schon eine
Kampfansage und was der Präsident damit
signalisieren möchte ist zu sagen
Amerika kann wie man das flap sich im
englischen amerikanischen sagen würde
walk and you gone it the same time will
sagen sie können sowohl sich in der
Ukraine engagieren und für die
Sicherheit Europas Sorgen wie
gleichzeitig und ist eben auch ein
Signal an die politischen Gegner die
jetzt immer ihm immer wieder einheizen
was sich China Frage angeht besonders
die taiwanfrage wir können auch
gleichzeitig unsere Interessen im
Indopazifik richten das ist die kann
Amerika das wirklich das war ja die
Kritik die Aufgaben so nach dem Motto
Amerika braucht die Waffen die jetzt an
die Ukraine gehen braucht Amerika
eigentlich für Tage sind nicht die
gleichen Waffensysteme also wenn es
unter waren ginge da ging es nicht um
155 mm Geschosse sondern da gings und
Maria da geht es um maritimes Gerät ja
umgekehrt wirft es natürlich schon jetzt
klassische Fragen auf der Beschaffung
das haben wir natürlich auch die ganzen
Problematiken die wir jetzt auch haben
auch mit einer neuen Chefin ist
beschaffungs oder der
beschaffungsdynamik in Deutschland aber
das wirft natürlich schon klassisch
Fragen auf aber wenn es um die Frage
Vorbereitung auf mögliche Situationen in
Taiwan geht ist die USA eigentlich
besser eingestellt wenn wir über moderne
Kriegsführung gedacht haben haben wir
eher an solche Situationen gedacht als
natürlich daran dass wir quasi wieder
Artillerie Munitionen aus dem alten
gewehrschrank rausholen müssen umgekehrt
ist das aber natürlich wahnsinnig teuer
ja die Amerikaner haben es jetzt gerade
geschafft ihre munitions ähm also Sie
haben es lang 14.000 Schuss quasi am
produzieren kann in der regulären
Produktionspalette 8000 verschießen die
die ukrainischen Kollegen mit einer
Schnelligkeit das heißt sie haben es
gerade geschafft dass sie es auch 20.000
Geschosse in der Produktion haben
hochfahren können über den Monat aber
sie müssten eigentlich dahin kommen dass
sie 90.000 bis 20 25 produzieren das
kostet ein wahnsinniges Geld das ist ein
Geld für diese Waffengattung und diese
Waffensysteme die einen Donald Trump
oder ein anderer Präsident nicht Chance
geben wollen wird also es ist ein
diplomatischer Tanz aber es ist eine
diplomatische Absicherung für Joe Biden
besonders einer der auch mit
außenpolitischen Themen große Ausnahme
in diesem neuen Wahlkampf auch Punkten
werden muss gerade gegenüber der
republikanischen Opposition und vor
allen Dingen gegenüber dem Kongress denn
der Präsident kann sein eigenes Geld
ausgeben aber die Hauptsache der der
Geldsack liegt natürlich weiterhin im
US-Kongress aber vermutlich ist es auch
kein Zufall dass genau auch an diesem
Wochenende dann eine erneute
Militärübung seitens China vor Taiwan
stattgefunden hat
China auf dieses Treffen in Camp David
mit große Nervosität mit großem nun muss
man auch faireweise sagen china hatte
dazu beigetragen also die chinesische
russische Marine
haben schon zweimal wirklich großer
Patrouillenfahrten gemeinsam gemacht
gegen die USA bis zu alle löschen Insel
bis an die Alaska Küste es ist eindeutig
ein
abschreckungsschritt nicht nur gegen die
USA sondern auch gegen die USA für
Verbündeten wie Japan die beiden
kriegsverbände also Flottenverbände
umkreisen japanischen Inseln also sie
sind nicht nicht nur die Idee die
äußeren sehen das heißt also je mehr die
truppenverzahnung zwischen China und
Russland stattfindet desto und nervöse
werden südkorea Japan desto größer ist
ihre Neigung in den USA jetzt einen viel
zuverlässigeres Bündnis einzugehen das
ist genau das Ergebnis in Camp David und
das schraubte die nächsten Spirale in
die Höhe sie sprechen jetzt diese
Militär Manöver an merkwürdigerweise
findet
nördlich genug um Japan und Korea zu
meinen ja sie findet ganz weltweit im
Süden statt gegenüber Taiwan was ist das
für ein Signal dass der Ort jetzt so
südlich ist das ist natürlich sehr
interessant und das ist ein chinesischer
Art zu sagen wir sind noch nicht so weit
euch direkt von Teil herauszufordern
aber wir reagieren woanders wo ihr auch
seid Taiwan zum Beispiel noch
interessanter den Philippinen also im
Moment brauche ich eine inselstreit
zusammen zwischen China und den
Philippinen um eine Insel die
chinesische Marine sind zweimal
eingeschritten zweimal zurückgezogen
jetzt sind sie zum dritten Mal wieder
angetan die die amerikanischen
Flugzeugträger Regen ist in der Region
es sieht ganz danach aus die
philippinische Präsident sagte wenn der
erste Schuss von uns nicht kommt denn
der zweite kommt ganz sicher aus unseren
Kanonen
warum versuchen sie im Südchinesischen
Meer so weit weg von der nordischen
gefahrenszenarien genau aus diesem Grund
weil sie sie es meinen wir können uns
nicht leisten zu nicht zu reagieren aber
wir können uns genauso wenig leisten
frontal zu reagieren wo ihr uns
herausfordert da schlagen wir zurück
nein nicht wir schlagen
im südlichen Meer zurück da ist es
sozusagen der weiche Unterbauch also so
ähm
andere Valley ja also dann ist es
natürlich in die Frage ob die
us-verbündnispolitik dann fruchtet also
zum Beispiel Frankreich macht sehr viel
Mitte die französische Navi Marine fährt
jetzt also
Flottenverbände Übungen mit Indonesien
zusammen die deutschen Verbände waren
mit der australischen Marine mit
singapurischen Marine Japaner helfen die
Philippinen und weder Frankreich und
teilweise auch Deutschland Hilft Vietnam
um zu zeigen nicht nur die Amerikaner
sind die Partner wir sind es auch wir
machen es auch auch wenn es sie in einem
kleineren Ausmaß diese bundespolitische
Bewegung und die werden die die Zukunft
dieser Welt weitgehend prägen jenseits
der Ukraine Jenseits das ist ja genau
das jetzt ist Frankreich schon
angesprochen wie erinnern uns macron
hatte ja dafür plädiert dass Europa in
der taiwanfrage gleichermaßen Distanz
hält zu China wie zu den USA
wie blicken die Franzosen auf dieses
Thema ist die macron Äußerung schon fast
wieder vergessen oder ist das etwas was
jetzt auch anlässlich dem was Herr
gerade ausgeführt hat in der Diskussion
ist
also seien wir ehrlich bei dem Otto
Normal Franzosen ist sie wahrscheinlich
dieser Äußerung längst verflogen ich
glaube das ist wir haben schon erwähnt
die haben auch andere Prioritäten auf
ihre Agenda aber in der Tat ist hat sie
in Frankreich und darüber hinaus
weltweit für Schlagzeilen gesorgt in
Deutschland hat wurde macron glaube ich
seit 20 17 noch nie so heftig kritisiert
also da hat man gemerkt spätestens da
ist die macron man ja in Deutschland der
erst von der ersten anzahlzeit das von
schon Präsidenten definitiv zu Ende
und ähm ich glaube
es ist noch ein bisschen ein Rest oder
eine Überbleibsel oder ein Wille noch
von dieser großen Mann von diesem
Großmacht Anspruch aus früheren Zeiten
ja wo Frankreich meine erinnere sich an
de Gaul also zwischen den USA und
Russland eine besondere Rolle spielen
wollte und da anscheinend will irgendwie
damit anknüpfen und
vergisst möglicherweise ein bisschen zu
schnell dass er eingebunden ist oder
eingebunden werden sollte in Bündnisse
wie die Europäische Union siehe
China-Politik
und seine seine Reise mit Ursula von der
Leyen dort oder oder die NATO ja und ich
glaube
das ist das ein bisschen ein Problem
wenn man gleichzeitig ein Anspruch hat
auf der internationalen Bühne eine Rolle
zu spielen gleichzeitig manche Partner
durch
schnell gesagt den Sprüche
verirritiert ja und macro hat in den
letzten Jahren also ein paar Male dafür
gesorgt die Natur sein Hirn tot etc
das sieht spätestens mit dem Ukraine
kriegen nicht zwanghafte so aus ja also
ich glaube das ist ein ein bisschen ein
Problem dieser
dieser makronischen Außenpolitik und
dieser und dieser Wille bachtur
irgendwie an eine an eine
vergangene grandeur zu halten also die
deutschen sagen nicht umsonst sprechen
nicht umsonst sehr häufig von der
Grundversion ein Begriff den wir in
Frankreich nicht benutzen
es ist vielleicht auch ein Versuch das
hatten wir jetzt klang ja schon bei
mehreren jetzt von ihnen an zum Teil
auch von innenpolitischen
Schwierigkeiten abzulenken die ist ja
unweigerlich überall gibt weil einfach
die Themen so groß sind und die
chinesische Wirtschaft in einem ganz
anderen Moment steckt aber natürlich
beispielsweise auch hier in Deutschland
sie haben es eingangs schon geschildert
sich noch mal ganz andere Fragen stellen
das heißt auf der einen Seite gibt es
diese ja muss man sagen so ein bisschen
militärlogik und neuen allianzfragen auf
der anderen Seite die innenpolitischen
Fragen jetzt bezogen auf Deutschland was
glauben Sie ja
wie geht Deutschland da jetzt weiter vor
das Zögern von Olaf Scholz haben wir
schon angesprochen und in der Tat gibt
es in der Ampelkoalition ja auch noch
das ein oder andere Thema ja genau es
sind eben einfach innenpolitische Themen
ins Zentrum der Debatte gerückt und das
sind ja Herausforderungen die kennen
deutsche seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr nicht
es gab jetzt aus der CDU beispielsweise
die Forderung nach einer Agenda 2030 in
Anlehnung an die Agenda 2010 und das was
da auf uns zukommt an auch Wohlstands
Einbußen teilweise das sorgt meiner
Meinung nach dafür dass in der
Bevölkerung eine starke Politisierung
stattfindet und man richtig hingeht und
fragt wofür geben wir denn unser Geld
aus lindner war ja gerade in Kiew und
hat von 22 Milliarden gesprochen die
bisher geflossen sind zwölf davon sind
12 Milliarden davon waren Militärhilfe
und das weitere so ein fließen werden
wir haben ja auch eine langfristige
Unterstützung zugesagt aber ich glaube
wenn die Bürger das Gefühl haben dass
ihr sozusagen unmittelbares auskommen
gefährdet ist dass designbussen
hinnehmen müssen dann gibt es auf jeden
Fall auch die Möglichkeit für
populistische Kräfte für Parteien diese
Stimmung der Unzufriedenheit
aufzugreifen und zu sagen schaut mal
wofür die Regierung euer Geld ausgibt
ist seit nicht nur ihr sondern es sind
zum Beispiel Leute in der Ukraine und
die AFD ist jetzt seit Wochen stabil auf
Platz 2 in den Umfragen in Deutschland
hat es noch nicht gegeben wir haben
Wahlen im Osten nächstes Jahr drei Stück
wir haben diesen Herbst noch zwei Wahlen
in Hessen und in Bayern und man sieht ja
wie aufgeht als die Stimmung sein kann
Herr Scholz war am Freitag in München
bayerischer Landtagswahlkampf da sind
ähm Leute mit thrillerpfeifen hau Abrufe
Buche auch Applaus aber die versuchen
ihn sozusagen zu übertönen und er lässt
sich dann eben auch dazu hinreisen zu
sagen ich sitze hier frei dass er einen
gefallenen Engel die da als
Friedenstauben verkleidet sein die
würden aus der Hölle kommen denn sie
redeten den kriegst aber Putin das Wort
und ich glaube in diese Konfrontation
weiterzugehen das ist gefährlich
weil wir haben einfach Kräfte in diesem
Land die sehen es gibt Unzufriedenheit
und die können diese Kräfte also
sozusagen diese Unzufriedenheit können
Sie in bestimmte Bahnen lenken diese
unzufriedenen das ist natürlich auch das
große Thema jetzt in dem Jahr
beginnenden US-Wahlkampf sie haben es
schon mehrfach anspringen ansprechen
können es geht ja auch bei diesem
Wahlkampf natürlich um die Milliarden
die ausgegeben werden für ein Land was
aus amerikanischer Sicht natürlich
erstmal unfassbar weit weg ist und
unfassbar weit weg natürlich auch von
den Problemen der normalen Amerikaner
ist was glauben Sie wie wird das jetzt
in den nächsten Monaten in diese
Strategie in diese westliche
reinspringen ja also ich glaube es
spielt eine große Rolle nur einen kurzen
Punkt zu der zu der bundesdeutschen
Debatte ich finde ist schwierig also ich
glaube das ist genau die Balance und das
muss aber eine gute funktionale
Regierung aushalten einerseits die
populistischen Kräfte im Land
zurücktreten zu können indem sie ihm die
besseren Argumente finden und das müssen
sie bis zum Schluss ausführen anstatt
hinzugehen und dann zu sagen na ja
wir überlegen jetzt doch eher das NATO
2% Ziel eben doch über die fünf Jahre zu
erreichen und aus der Sprache des
Bundeshaushalts rauszunehmen und so da
entsteht sowohl für die internationalen
Leser wie eben auch intern eine Dynamik
zu sagen naja meint also kann man eine
Bundesregierung entsprechend so
drangsalieren oder umgekehrt
offensichtlich kritisieren deutlich
gemacht aber umgekehrt ist es immer die
Frage ist Deutschland ein verlässlicher
Partner und kann diese Bundesregierung
apropos Agenda 2030 wirklich über die
nächste Bundestag sind Wahl hinaus
denken geht es um eine Strategie für das
Land eine Zukunftsvision oder geht es um
internes Koalition Gerangel das finde
ich sehr sehr schwierig in den USA
stellt sich natürlich diese Dynamik auf
unterschiedliche Art und Weise es gibt
die ganz traditionellen Republikaner die
sagen also Senator Wicker und die
regional Republikaner die sagen wenn wir
es ernst meinen quasi mit dem
rücktrennende Kommunismus und noch mal
auf die Sprache ist der 80er
zurückzugreifen
kann diese Menschen sagen muss ich sehr
viel schneller gehen muss sehr viel mehr
ausgegeben werden umgekehrt gibt's die
lautstarke aber eben dennoch immer noch
kleine Gruppe innerhalb des Kongresses
die mad GATS und majory Taylor Greens
dieser Welt also die klassischen
trumpisten die eben sagen nein das Geld
muss für unsere eigene Menschen
ausgegeben werden schaut man nach Hawaii
schaut man nach nahina schaut man auf
eine Bevölkerung die wirklich leidet in
vielerlei Hinsicht und die nicht
verstanden hat was so beiden über die
letzten zweieinhalb Jahre mit einem
weitgehende Infrastrukturprogramm mit
einem Umbau des amerikanischen
Sozialstaat erreichen wollen die
Inflationsdruck ist in den USA zwar viel
geringer und Arbeitsmarkt boomt aber
dennoch das Empfinden der Menschen und
deswegen ist es ein so enger Wahlkampf
jedenfalls wenn man Trump und beiden
nebeneinander stellen das ist eng weil
die Menschen bestimmte Dinge nicht
verstanden haben umgekehrt haben wir
aber jetzt eben schon in den letzten
Wochen gehört was ein Donald Trump in
seiner zweiten Amtszeit vor hätte und da
geht es ganz aggressiv anders das
funktionales bei der ersten
dysfunktionalen Amtszeit darum den in
Anführungszeichen tiefen Start abzubauen
also die Bürokratie zu entkernen in den
USA das Justizsystem weiter umzubauen da
gibt es ganz dezidierte Pläne von der
Heritage Foundation und von im Grunde
genommen angesehenen Think Tanks die
dafür sorgen würden dass wir mit einer
trump-wahl eine
exekutiv-diktatur haben würde ich mal
sagen es ist keine volle Diktatur aber
es ist bewegt sich dahin und umgekehrt
haben wir natürlich eben diese vier
Anklagepunkte die ins Haus stehen die
quasi die große Frage stellen kann die
amerikanische Demokratie durch den
Justizapparat immer noch das ernten was
ein z.B als noch mal und viele viele
natürlich aber Mike Pens als große
republikanische Stimme auch im Wahlkampf
als wir gehen gegen die amerikanische
Verfassung gesehen hat also
innenpolitische Sprache Prozesse wie
schätzen sie denn überhaupt die
Aussichten ein dass Trump äh ja welche
Chancen hätte er bei einer Wahl im
nächsten Jahr also wenn man seine wenn
man seine
Unterstützer fragt dann sind die immer
noch zu einer ganz großen Mehrheit bei
ihm 70% glauben weiterhin die große Lüge
der verlorenen Wahl also der
elegitimität eines Joe bidens im Weißen
Haus an sich das spült einem Herrn Trump
die Parteikassen voll die ja wegen
uriger Art und Weise der
Parteifinanzierung auch für seine seine
gerichtsberg also für sein seine
liege-teams gebrauchen kann alles sehr
urig es wird um Zeit gehen es wird um
also ich schaue sehr genau besonders auf
den Prozess in Georgia weil er der 18
mit Ankläger hat die vorher sehr auf die
windtrommel schlagen können aber wenn
ein Hoodie Giuliani vor einem
Geschworenengericht steht kann er kann
er eben nicht falsch aussagen das heißt
und dieser Prozess wenn er denn
innerhalb des Viertel als das
Bundesstaates Georgia bleibt das will
hat schon natürlich auch nicht äh wird
im Fernsehen gezeigt also das heißt
anders als diese Prozesse um den 6
Januar herum die quasi ähm ja von von
einem nebensänder gezeigt wurden das
werden das würde im nächsten Jahr das
Fernsehen geschehen bestimmen und dann
wird es schwer zu sein zu sehen wie das
für Herren Trump glimpflich ausgewählt
das heißt Herr Trump spielt ähnlich wie
Herr Putin auf Zeit und auf die
Gerichtsbarkeit der amerikanischen
Wähler wenn er nämlich diese ganzen
Prozesse nach hinten verlegen kann das
ist das ist für mich gesehen der einzige
Weg wie er quasi noch den Weg ins Weiße
Haus finden kann wenn er das aber tut
entsteht eine grundgefährliche Situation
nicht nur für die USA sondern eben wie
gesagt für die ganze Welt Infrastruktur
also es ist natürlich
aber wenn Herr beiden schlimm stützen
sollte er ist ja offensichtlich etwas
fragil dann sieht das natürlich noch mal
anders aus und die Leute die nachher
schon bekommen die sind ja teilweise gar
nicht anders nicht also meiner mein
Gefühl ist die Amerikaner sehen sich
auch nach einem jungen Kandidaten der in
der Lage wäre sozusagen eine gewisse
Normalität auszustrahlen nicht sozusagen
diese aggressive existierte Art von
Herrn und auf der anderen Seite auch
nicht sozusagen dieses doch singer
citizen like Verhalten von Damen und
Herren beiden da gibt es jetzt einen
neuen Kandidaten der hat gestern
gleichgezogen mit Herrn Disentis und der
hat ja ganz außergewöhnliche Ideen
beispielsweise will er irgendwie die
Russen von den Chinesen lösen sagt wir
müssen die großen auf unsere Seite
ziehen er sagt er würde als zweiter
Nixen sozusagen hingehen ja
mittelfristig auch Herr Trumps planen
also ich meine und das würde dann aber
rausnehmen andere das dann womöglich
erfüllen 10% weiterhin noch weit
abgeschlagen viel gefährlicher ist
eigentlich die Bewegung eine dritte
Partei zu gründen und das ist also das
haben wir ja schon gesehen bei Rose also
Navi ist George Bush damals ein seiner
Präsidentschaft gekommen und andere wenn
eine Drittpartei sich einschließt und
das scheint eben auch der Fall zu sein
mit no Labels in zehn Bundesstaaten
jetzt schon vertreten das könnte sehr
sehr schwierig werden und das wiederum
weil die Zahlen so eng sind könnte für
einen beiden noch eine ganz andere
Herausforderung bedeuten kommen sicher
gleich auch noch mal zu diesen Fragen
die letzte Viertelstunde hier im
international Frühschoppen die gehört ja
immer den Zuhörern und den zuschauernden
mit ihren Fragen und wir beginnen mit
Kai Riedel aus Geesthacht guten Morgen
du moin Moin ich musste dem eigentlich
habe ich tausend Fragen ich würde mich
am liebsten mal bei Ihnen die Runde
setzen
leider eine Frage bitte ja ich weiß was
mich wirklich wundert und schockiert und
vielleicht können wir es ja irgendjemand
erklären sie hatten vier Jahre Trump wir
haben gelernt dass die USA alles andere
zuverlässiger Partner sein kann wie kann
es sein dass wir wenn es um einen Krieg
auf europäischen Boden gehen über einen
Krieg auf europäischen wohnen reden
ratzfatz bei den Interessen von Amerika
sind und nicht bei den von Europa
an wen möchten Sie die Frage am liebsten
richten
zu antworten
ja also ich glaube die Europäer haben
schon gemerkt dass sie sehr sehr viel
nachjustieren müssen und ich bin
umgekehrt muss man den Europäern ja
einiges zusprechen sie haben wahnsinnig
viel geleistet für ihre Umstände ich
glaube trotzdem ist in keiner
europäischen Hauptstadt wirklich die
Möglichkeit angekommen dass in einer
zweiten Trump oder republikanischen
Präsidentschaft der Stecker der NATO
rausgezogen werden könnte sie dann
wirklich auf sich selber gestellt werden
könnten also eine europäische
friedensfazilität einzurichten ein
friedensinstrument was zumindest mal so
heißt um es dann zu benutzen um
atelierie Munition Produktion in in
Europa zu finanzieren und damit in
kostenvorlage zu gehen das ist doch für
das Friedensprojekt Europa ein ziemlich
großer Schritt gewesen umgekehrt eine
andere Angleichung zwischen Europäischer
Union und der NATO in diesem auch ähm
auch im G7 Kontext zu bekommen es hat
sich viel getan in Europa aber hat es
sich hat es genug getan um die
Interessen dann im Zweifel alleine
verteidigen zu können
das ist eben das glaube ich ähm und das
geht auch dahin zu sagen wie ehrlich
kann man mit seinen Wählern sein welche
ja welche Abschlags oder wie muss man
dann andere Dinge neu verhandeln in der
Priorität das traut sich zurzeit kein
einziger europäischer Staatschef und das
könnte wirklich noch sehr gefährlich
werden
und wir gehen nach Aachen zu Alexander
Carabas guten Tag ja guten Tag schöne
Grüße aus Achim ich höre jetzt mit
Interesse hier Sendung da und dann
wollte ich etwas dazu sagen zu dem
Vorschlag das gleiche so die Ukraine
eingehüllen da rein abgibt vielleicht
auch mal das Russland an die Ukraine was
zurück gibt es eine Sache die bei 100
Jahren meine Familie betroffen hatte und
zwar meine Familie kriechen letztes
Jahrhunderten der Türkei und da gab es
aber auch dann Hunderttausende von
Türken die Letten in balkern immerzeugen
und da gab es also immer Linde Krach
dabei heute auch dann ging es hin Leute
besser zum Beispiel also mein älteste
Onkel jagen 1880 wie ihr hier in der
sich 180 ich hatte gute Geschäfte in der
Türkei gemacht ein jüngerer Bruder von
ihm ist das türkische
Richtung Frage kommen damit möglichst
viele Zuhörer dran kommen
danke gewesen
[Musik]
bis vor 100 Jahren die beschlossen haben
unsere Völker aus eineinhalb Griechen
sind von der Türkei eine Griechenland
gegangen 800 000 Türken sind schon wir
haben leider nur die Zeit dass sie
einmal die Frage kurz formulieren
etwa vor 100 Jahren geklappt hat und zu
seitdem also gibt es also keinen Krieg
zwischen Türkei und Griechenland warum
versucht man das heute nicht ja wer mag
Antworten
also fast gerade beschrieben wurde ist
sind das Thema Friedensverträge und es
gab viele Friedensverträge nach Kriegen
auch nach außen an der Setzungen seien
sie bilateral oder darüber hinaus
weil sie da gerade Ansprachen ist
natürlich möglicherweise verbunden mit
dem Ersten Weltkrieg äh und da hat man
manchmal ganz lang Karten neu
gezeichnet
daher ist es nicht neu ich wir haben
gerade vorher besprochen also wie mühsam
es ist erstmal müsste Moskau oder von
seinen absoluten Zielen abrücken also
Russland möchte die Ukraine immer länger
vernichten und die Ukraine möchte sein
international anerkannteste Territorium
gänzlich zurückbekommen sind sie dazu
bereit wann ja um bis wann ähm ein
ganzer Umtausch sehe ich nicht also
außerdem habe ich den Eindruck dass der
Krieger dazu geführt hat das wesentlich
dass da jetzt die überwältigende
Mehrheit der Leute in der Ukraine sich
zu keiner fühlen und dass die wenn sie
auf die russische Minderheit oder die
russische Minderheit dann spielen ich
glaube nicht dass es die heute eine
Bedeutung spielt also klar das ist das
ist möglich aber das haben wir vorher
besprochen in der Sendung
dass das erfordert ein vielleicht ein
eine Änderung der kriegerischen
ausländersitzungen auf dem Grund und
außerdem ein Bewegung eine Bewegung der
der zwei Parteien und Druck
wahrscheinlich auch von der
ausländischen von der
internationalgemeinschaft und wir machen
weiter mit traute Hammerer aus Bergheim
Erft guten Tag guten Tag guten Morgen
Ich habe die Sendung verfolgt immer habe
ich immer wieder gern und habe eine
Frage ich traue Herrn willenski nicht
und er hat jetzt schon ein paar mal vor
Mikrofonen betont dass er verspricht
keine westlichen Waffen in Russland
einzusetzen ja was ist denn mit den
anderen
also die Fragen was ist mit den Waffen
die die Ukraine selber besitzt oder
sogar selber produziert und ob sie die
gegen russisches Territorium einsetzen
kann tatsächlich ist das nach dem
Völkerrecht legitim man kann ein
Aggressor auch auf seinem eigenen
Territorium angreifen gleichzeitig haben
die Ukraine
gezeigt dass sie eine große
Zurückhaltung walten lassen was diese
Angriffe auf russischem Territorium
angeht das hat natürlich damit zu tun
dass sie wissen dass die westlichen
Waffenlieferung auch damit sozusagen
daran gebunden sind dass diese Waffen
aber auch andere Waffen nicht zu einer
Eskalation eines Krieges führen wo auf
russischem Territorium wirklich im
russischen Territorium gekämpft wird und
womöglich dann eben die NATO mit den
Krieg gezogen werden könnte deswegen
keiner also die Ukraine haben sich da
bisher sehr zurückhaltend gezeigt und
sie haben manche Sachen doch keinen
Anlass diese dieses Vorgehen zu ändern
ja danke schön und wir hören Michael
Hagen aus Pforzheim guten Tag hallo
guten Tag
der Ukraine könnte auch wenn der Westen
zu einem Sieg Russland führen und da
habe ich die Frage dass die deutsche
Bevölkerung überwiegenden Osten das
nicht versteht dass sie dann wieder die
DDR aufleben lassen
nach Europa einmarschiert und die EU
weiterhin uneinig ist
das war meine Frage ja danke also wir
sind ja in der NATO das heißt wir sind
ja in einem starken Bündnis wo wir uns
gegenseitig so denn ein Angriff der
Russischen Föderation auf ein
NATO-Mitglied erfolgen wurde verteidigen
würden bzw unsere Partner und zu Hilfe
eilen sollten aber eine Sache finde ich
doch interessant auch in der Ankündigung
ihrer Sendung wird der Begriff
Hilfsbereitschaft benutzt wie lange hält
die Hilfsbereitschaft des Westens noch
es geht aber nicht um die moralische
Qualität ist Bereitschaft sondern um
unsere eigenen
Sicherheitsinteressen und ich glaube das
auch ein signifikanter Unterschied
zwischen der Perspektive in Deutschland
in den Vereinigten Staaten in den USA
denkt man über die Interessen nach was
bedeutet das für uns wir haben auch
Unterstützung formuliert
Hilfsbereitschaft ich hatte einmal
gelesen
genau aber es ist ein Punkt der auch
viele Leute die uns zu hören auf Twitter
umtreibt einen User schreibt die meisten
Bürger auch ich haben bis vor einer
Woche noch nie von diesen Taurus Dingern
gehört der soll da beurteilen ob sie
geliefert werden oder Matthias Obst
fragt er soll das alles finanzieren und
wo wird dafür eingespart also das sind
in der Tat die Fragen die die Menschen
umtreiben und wir haben noch Zeit
für Peters aus Bad Soden guten Tag
hallo die Entscheidung welche Waffen
geliefert werden sollen muss von
Experten nach militärischen Fakten
entschieden werden und nicht nach
Meinungsumfragen und die
Waffenlieferungen bisher gegen viel zu
langsam das hat Russland ausgenutzt
besetzt historium vermiet und
Panzersperren aufgebaut die akine muss
den Krieg gewinnen ansonsten wäre das
eine moralische Erklärung für den Westen
und der Kriegsverbrecher Putin dafür
seine Schweinereien nicht belohnt werden
danke das ist ein starkes Statement mag
jemand noch antworten oder lassen wir
das für den Moment so stehen dann
würde ich noch mal Andreas Barz aus
sauensieg hören guten Tag guten Tag an
die Runde
ich habe eigentlich eine ganz einfache
Frage aber ich glaube das sind relativ
schwierige Antwort wir nehmen mal an die
Ukraine hat alle setzen Gebiete inklusiv
der Krim zurückerobert jetzt stellt sich
die Frage erkennt das Russland dann an
und hört auch mit der Bombardierung von
den ganzen Städten auf oder geht das
dann weiter denn der Spruch gilt ja noch
kriegt zu Beginn ist ganz einfach aber
beenden ganz schwierig danke schön ja
danke für die Frage das ist das was wir
ja auch schon diskutiert haben und es
könnte weiterhin im Interesse sein dann
einfach diesen gefrorenen Konflikt immer
weiter und immer wieder zu produzieren
provozieren und als nuklear macht
russland hat natürlich im Russland
einfach noch bestimmte Waffengattungen
in der hintertasche die eine Situation
immer weiterhin brandgefährlich machen
könnte und noch mal um aufhören Tibo
einzugehen und die Frage die vorher kam
russland hat eine de Popularisierung end
Bevölkerung eine neue schichtige
Bevölkerung quasi russische
Bevölkerungsgruppen in den Osten der
Ukraine neues auf die Creme geschleust
also das ist da im klassischen Sinne so
wie es auch in Südafrika gesehen haben
so eine große Trends editional justice
also wirklich ein Ausgleich auch
zwischen Bevölkerungsgruppen gehen
müssen die man dann auch ausnutzen kann
die ein Herr putinpropagandistisch
ausnutzen kann das werden alles ganz
ganz schwierige ganz komplexe ganz
langwierige Situationen Verhandlungen
aber Russland hat weiterhin im hinter in
der Hinterhand ein komplett
modernisiertes nukleares Arsenal das
heißt um auf einen Friedensvertrag ein
Waffenstillstand zu kommen der anders
als bei Minsk dann auch wirklich hält
wird es eine gesamt internationale
Anstrengung brauchen und bedürfen alle
Druckverhältnisse inklusive Pekings
müssen eingespielt werden und dazu
müssen wir erstmal über das nächste
schwierige ja kommen 2024 ja und Regine
Volkmann aus Caputh guten Tag ich habe
eine Frage es wird hier in der Runde
teilweise
und doch allgemein über Waffen und
Waffen und Waffen gesprochen kann mir
einer aus der Runde oder irgendwoher
sagen wie viel Menschen leben schon mit
diesen Waffen gerettet wurden die wir
liefern
ich finde also Krieg ein Frieden mit mit
mehr Waffen erreicht man nicht und was
mich besonders schockiert ist immer
wieder es reden immer wieder Leute
darüber mehr Waffenlieferungen die nie
in diesem Krieg kämpfen müssen das sogar
der habe ich mal gesagt ich werde nicht
in diesem Krieg kämpfen müssen ich werde
da nicht sterben und es finde ich
absolut zynisch muss ich doch endlich
die Weltgemeinschaft mal zusammenrücken
und die beiden Partner und alle und
endlich um Frieden kämpfen damit nicht
noch mehr mehr Menschen sterben müssen
oder verletzt werden also das ist mein
Mann
ich denke also vielleicht ist es nur
meine persönliche Beobachtung dass die
Pazifismus
Diskussion hier in Europa in Deutschland
Frankreich deutlich nachgelassen hat
aber
wenn das eine Krieg gibt wenn der Krieg
im Gange ist dann hat der Krieg eine
eigene Logik dann ist es nicht mehr nur
eine moralische Appell der diese Logik
brechen kann wir haben nicht nur die
Erfahrung mit zwei Weltkriegen wir haben
auch so viele vertrete Kriege im Nahen
Osten überall in der Welt überall galt
eben oder gilt auch immer hoch immer
noch diese Kriegslogik und deswegen
denke ich ist in Bezug auf die Zukunft
zum Beispiel Pazifik und so dann müssen
wir wirklich eine andere pazifistische
Diskussion jetzt schon anfangen will mir
schon sehen dass die Logik hier in
Europa nicht zu brechen ist also wer vom
wer versuchen alles um einen Krieg zu
vermeiden und meinen Kriege
zuvorzukommen einschließlich auch
Waffenlieferungen zum Beispiel in Japan
Südkorea Taiwan eben weil ein Aggressor
am Ende doch auch noch berechnen muss
kann er das überhaupt noch leisten kann
es ist überhaupt nur gewinnen wir
erinnern uns dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine begonnen hatte weil die Europäer
den dem dem dem Krimml ein falsches
Signal gesendet haben einschließlich
deutsche ja unser du kannst weit kommen
ganz kurz vielleicht noch einmal
wirklich die Frage der Zuschauer und war
ja wie viel Menschenleben sind gerettet
worden durch den Einsatz von Waffen
finden wer da vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz darauf antworten dann naja wenn die
Russen die Ukraine überrannt hätten und
ähnliche Vorgänge von denen wir aus
ihren oder Butcher gehört haben im
ganzen Land stattgefunden hätten oder
ist eine massive Flüchtlingswelle den
Westen gegeben hätte also absolutes
Chaos dann geben sprechen wenn er
natürlich schon über
ich muss auch ehrlich sagen ich will
mich gar nicht hundertprozentig
festlegen was für Größenordnung sind da
bin ich auch kein Experte aber natürlich
ist sozusagen die demokratische Existenz
der Ukraine dadurch gesichert worden ich
weiß nicht wie man eine Runde eine Zahl
nennen könnte für Leute das ist super
schwierig eine Zahl ist glaube ich sehr
sehr schwer festzulegen umgekehrt sie
haben eingangs genannt was es bedeutet
hat in einem Kriegsgeschehen zu sein
aber umgekehrt dass wir trotz der
schweren Kämpfe in der Osten und
südost-ukraine ein Leben haben im Westen
das auf jeden Falls täglich selbst der
ständigen Bedrohung der Angstzustände
der Traumata die Menschen haben
aushalten müssen im Butter wird
glücklicherweise wieder aufgebaut ich
habe mit dem Bürgermeister dort länger
gesprochen ist wahnsinnige wunderbare
Dinge passieren da aber dass sie diese
Demokratie und zum zumindest bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt auch noch eine
Wirtschaftsleistung der Ukraine
einigermaßen erhalten können und das mit
dem Wunsch der Ukraine entsprechen eine
funktionale westliche integrierte
Demokratie zu sein denn darauf muss es
ja wirklich abzählen und einen wenn ein
Russland sich nicht an einen
Verhandlungstisch bewegen möchte
ihnen noch mal dass sie darauf nochmal
reagiert haben ich danke Ihnen sehr
herzlich fürs zusehen und wünsche Ihnen
jetzt noch einen schönen Sonntag hier
aus Köln
[Musik]